[Music]
good morning everybody thank you all for
getting up here very early on the very
last day of the conference for the
exciting topic of billing I'm glad that
you all realize how important it is to
actually understand what your business
is in what it costs your business to run
your software lots of people don't
understand how important this topic is
usually they think it's really boring so
glad that you actually understand my
name is Evan Jones I'm a software
engineer at blue core and we're going to
talk today about going beyond your bill
and getting more detail on cost so first
we're going to talk a little bit about
blue course cost challenges and how I
got involved in this we're then going to
talk about Google's existing cost
management tools what they give you out
of the box we're then gonna talk about
how you can create some of your own data
sources when you need more detail on
what things start costing you and then
finally we're going to talk a little bit
about some of the lessons that that
we've learned at blue core about this
and we're going to have plenty of time
for Q&A because I tend to talk way too
quickly all right so first the reason I
got involved in this is I started
getting all these questions like hey why
is our bill so high why did February
cost us 123 thousand dollars or hey why
did our bill go up why is February cost
twenty-three thousand twenty three
thousand dollars more than what January
did or what happened on this day what
happened on October 25th to cause our
cost to be really high just a quick show
of hands is anybody here had to answer
questions like that for your business
all right
great the rest of you don't worry though
someone in your company will eventually
figure out that you do in fact know how
to answer these questions because every
single organization needs to know the
answer to these sorts of questions great
so so why did we get here so blue car we
are a a six year old startup we do
intelligent ecommerce marketing we've
been around for six years based in New
York we now have about 180 employees our
customers are hundreds of large
retailers so we are a
software-as-a-service application and we
sell to customers like Sephora Express
Tommy Hilfiger and other brands that I'm
sure you would recognize the company
started with the intention of saying
that email marketing for e-commerce
isn't really being done correctly the
traditional approach is a retailer just
sends the same content to every single
customer that's ever shopped on their
website and blue course started with the
intention of we should customize that
and provide people information that's
actually relevant to the
in this email so as an example of what
that looks like here's an email that we
send for Timberland it says other
popular purchases and has three
suggested products at the bottom the
point of this is this is a message that
the marketer had Timberland has
configured to send to their customers
after they've completed a purchase and
then these products that are shown at
the bottom are come from our
recommendation algorithms and so these
have been customized for the recipient
of this email maybe it's based on the
product that they already purchased or
some of the other shopping history that
they may have with this retailer so
these types of personalized messages are
more effective but there is a
disadvantage and the disadvantage is
this is what our Google Cloud cost bill
looks like in all of the slides in this
presentation I've had to remove the
actual dollar values and the y-axis here
so you'll have to apologize but this is
in fact our real Google Cloud bill this
is our top-level Bill daily cost
starting in January 1st 2017 through
until February of 2019 this is as much
data as the built-in Google Cloud
billing console would give us now
because of some of these spikes and
variations that may not be extremely
obvious but this is actually a 3x
increase over two years this is 75%
annual growth now for me this is a great
problem to have as an engineer I love
this because this means we've got to go
now and figure out how to optimize this
and solve this it also means that our
business is growing so like this is
actually a really good problem to have
but we do want to make sure that our
growth is in line with our business or
ideally actually grows slower than our
actual growth in our business right
which would improve the profitability of
the business so because this has
happened we've needed to start looking
into all of these questions like ok so
why is our bill so high where is that
money going the top level cost like this
doesn't actually show you a whole lot of
information besides hey you're spending
more money than you used to but I do
think it's interesting there are a few
interesting trends you can see here so
at this far left mark here at around
November or December of 2017 is Black
Friday we have a very seasonal business
people do a lot of shopping starting
between Thanksgiving and the end of the
year and so that spike there is there
increase for 2017 we have an extremely
large peak there which is in about
October that was when we went and did
low testing for Black Friday we want to
make sure that every year we can handle
the load that we're going to
see we go and try to break our own
systems it turns out that costs a little
bit of money so that's what that
particular spike is for on that
particular day and then you can see
Brock Friday 2018 so you can see here
for blue core we tend to have this thing
where our costs kind of go up and then
they go up a heck of a lot starting in
November and then they kind of stay that
level and then they go up the next
November and then they kind of stay at
that level okay great so when we had
these questions about cost when we were
smaller with about 10 software engineers
we would just go to the All Hands
meeting and be like hey where did our
cost increase come from last Thursday
something must have happened
or you know data store cost is up our
App Engine cost is up whatever did
somebody do something and usually
somebody there would be like oh yep I
think we turned on this new data feature
let me go look into see if that's what's
causing the cost increase we could go
find it and solve the problem now that
we're bigger if we have about 40 or so
engineers that doesn't actually work
anymore we have too many changes in too
much complexity so when we go and ask
that question at the All Hands meeting
people are just like I have no idea we
changed all sorts of things maybe one of
our customers started using a feature in
a new way that changed how our
application runs so we needed to go and
do something to answer these questions
so cloud providers like Google provided
you this nice advantage there's really
really clear pricing go look at the
price sheet to go see what something
costs you and they provide you this nice
detailed bill at the every single day to
tell you what you actually used in what
things cost before I started at blue
core I came from an organization that
own its own servers and so I kind of
assumed that this would not be a problem
in the cloud universe because you have
this nice detailed bill you want to know
what something costs just look at your
bill it turns out that that is true for
things that are separate so for example
if you have fairly separable
applications and you can have say a
separate Google Cloud project for your
team or for your feature Google built in
bill probably will give you the level of
detail you need it will tell you hey
this team cost this much here's all the
line items that this team actually used
and that may actually be sufficient so
if that works for you that's great but
there are things that have to be shared
in our case blue core is a
software-as-a-service application so at
least it's some sort of high-level
logical level
we have one application that is used by
all of our customers and so we end up
with some fairly big line items because
of that there's other good examples of
this one that I really like is like your
your data warehouse for your
organization the whole point of your
data warehouse is to put all the data
from your various different pieces into
one database but then all on in your
organization can access to be able to
learn the insights that they need to by
some definition that has to be like a
shared resource for your whole
organization so you're going to end up
with some things that are shared and are
going to be big line items on your bill
that you may want to go get more detail
about so for blue core what we really
wanted is we really wanted to know what
is our cost per team per engineering
team we want to be able to have that
accountability to say hey these five
people on data science your bill went up
last month can you go investigate if
that's expected or if there's a problem
here or you know hey this email feature
that just got turned on by this team
maybe it turns out that that's you know
more expensive than we thought it was
going to be maybe we need to optimize
that like we also wanted to know what
our cost is per customer so we our
software as a service application it'd
be really nice for us to look hey for
some of our large customers what does it
cost us to actually provide the service
to them do we have the right pricing
model on our finance team really wants
to know projections you know it turns
out that they would like to know six
months from now what is our Google Cloud
bill going to be they're really unhappy
when it's changing all the time which it
is so they want to be able to have some
model to look forward and say great what
is it going to cost us in six months or
the next year what will it cost us if we
sign this particularly large deal with
this particular customer that has some
specific needs can we negotiate or
customize their contract we need to know
what it's going to cost us to serve them
so these things are somewhat
organizations specific what blue core
wants for the cost per team or our cost
per customer is not what you are going
to need and but the point is these are
fairly generic things it and you can
sort of tweak these things to suit your
organization so it is it an overview
here's what we've done a blue core to
break down our bill our step one is put
everything into bigquery we already use
bigquery a heck of a lot so that's a
convenient place you could put it into
some other thing but you need to put the
data in one fit place so you can go and
analyze it we then combine Google's
other data sources to get some
additional levels of detail and we'll
talk about more specific details about
which ones in a moment and then step
three is for things where we don't have
enough detail from those existing google
data sources we actually go and
instrument the code to add that level of
detail the end result is you can make
metrics that matter to your team from
blue core it's that cost per customer or
that cost per engineering team but maybe
for you it's something else this you can
do that by customizing the existing data
that is available on Google Cloud so as
a quick example here's this is sorry for
this graph isn't super visible but
here's a quick example of what this
actually looks like this is our cost by
type over the last twenty days this is
effectively our engineering team so you
can see this top line at the very top
this is the email cost and you can see
that in February 26 it was fairly high
and then it actually decreased because
we deployed some sort of optimization
and then the next line here is events so
you can see for blue core those are
really the two big cost drivers it's a
ingesting data onto our platform which
is events and then sending emails which
is email there's a bunch of these other
teams that other line items at the
bottom from a cost optimization
perspective we can kind of ignore them
because they're a small part of our bill
here's a table that was created by
somebody on our finance team using this
data again I can't actually show you any
of the data so this is just the column
headers off of this table this is
showing the 25 lowest margin customers
and I really love this table shows the
brand name the monthly recurring revenue
for last month the total email and event
cost and then a computed margin that is
an email and event margin that is how
profitable or unprofitable it is as well
as a total email sense the thing I love
about this table is that our finance
team created this without the
engineering team doing anything all
we've done is we've provide this cost
per customer with this email and event
cost and they combined it with the
existing data about how much revenue
we're getting per customer to produce
this table and this table has been super
useful because we go and look at this
and be like hey why is customer X
costing us so much that's really weird
and then inevitably when that happens we
go and look at it and turns out there's
some sort of configuration issue or
they're using some particular weird part
of the product in a way that we didn't
expect and we can go and actually fix
that and actually improve these problems
so this has been super super helpful and
again
part I love is the engineering team had
nothing to do with this the finance team
actually created this themselves so this
is just an example of the kind of things
that you can do once you actually
instrument your bill to the level of
detail that you need alright let's talk
about how we can actually do this first
let's talk about the existing cost
management tools that Google provides
the first thing that you really should
look at and certainly I look at for any
cost problem is the google cloud billing
reports blue core has been a google
cloud customer for long enough that this
billing report did not use to exist it
does now exist it's actually useful if
you haven't played with it you should it
looks like
the screenshot shown here on the right
it will show you your cost per project
per service per line item or SKU sliced
over different time ranges it lets you
slice and dice this how you want it's
pretty useful the part that is still
unfortunate though is that there are
things like this big blue bar here at
the top that like it can't provide you
any more detail than the line item and
project level so why is this big blue
bar so high we're going to have to go do
some work to figure that out so the
first step to figuring out why the heck
this single line item is so large is to
get the actual raw data the this is
where the billing export comes in this
lets you get your detailed cost data
exported directly to bigquery there's
also a JSON export I don't find that to
be as useful if there's one thing that
you take away from this you should go
turn this feature on today the reason is
you can't go back in time and get the
detailed billing data for data in the
past so if you are going to want to do
cost analysis at some point in the next
say year and are going to want to look
back at cost data from today you need to
go turn this on today it probably won't
cost you anything if you're not using
bigquery very much anyway what it gives
you is it gives you this sort of
detailed data that's shown on the right
we're going to talk a little bit about
it in a moment
about the actual Google Cloud bill and
there's some sort of schema for this
there's lots of documentation ok so what
do you get when you actually if you're
actually working with this data how
should you actually work with it a few
tips that are useful to know first thing
is Google builds you the Google's
official billing time is Pacific time
days so Mountain View standard time you
can convert the billing data into this
time zone
using this bigquery function here
time-stamped trunk take the usage start
time and convert it into this America
Los Angeles timezone now you'll get days
that are the same days that Google
actually uses which is useful when you
want to compare this to your bill some
of the data is delayed it's a small
percentage it keeps decreasing it last I
looked before making this talk in
February it was something like point 1
percent usually that data is delayed
only by a day or two sometimes it's a
little bit more but but not much the
point here is if you want to do use this
data you're going to have to process you
know chunks of time or or reprocess it
or delay your processing a little bit to
make sure that you actually capture all
of it tax and Corrections show up much
later tax shows up at the end of the
month if you have Corrections or credits
they will show up way later this can
also screw up your analysis so you may
end up having to again reprocess this
data multiple times to sort of get the
correct view and the other thing is
there this schema is has human
descriptions in it it has a SKU
description and a project description or
receive me a product description and
these can change the most recent change
was Google changed this from calling it
standard instance CPU and standard
instance Ram to predefined instance CPU
and RAM this is totally fine if you're
doing some ad hoc analysis and just
looking at like what was the cost last
week if you're trying to do some
analysis over say a year you're going to
want to use the ID fields that Google
provides and now you have the problem is
that those aren't human understandable
ok what does this actually look like so
let's go and recreate this graph from
the Google billing report this is
showing us the top skews by day this
month these are their top Google Cloud
billing line items for the current month
broken down each day so that was what
the screenshot was that we showed before
on the left-hand side and on the
right-hand side is the sort of bigquery
results that we want which have the day
as well as then the actual line item
here like the front-end instance
datastore cloud datastore read
operations what does this look like
here's the example query you don't have
to understand it I am going to walk
through a couple of the parts that are
somewhat important to give you a sense
about what the actual raw google billing
data looks like the first thing here is
this day this is this magic conversion
to Google standard billing days
so timestamp trunk that you should start
time to this America Los Angeles
timezone again we want to actually go
and compare to our actual Google Cloud
bill you're going to want to convert to
that day if you want to be able to do
that
this skewed description this is this
human readable description of that line
item and then we want to sum our cost
and this sort of magic expression here
with this cool s on nest thing is
bigquery magic to say hey take the
credits that are attached that line item
and just sum them all up as well so when
you have credits like say the the
sustained usage discount in compute
engine there can be multiple credits
attached to a single line item we want
to add all of those credits together to
get the actual cost after the credits
have been applied we want to take the
sum of days since the beginning of the
month so that's this timestamp trunk to
the month and this partition time magic
again you'll have to understand this and
then we want to sum that all these
things together the final result is
going to look something like this
this is blue cores actual top line items
for March 16th front-end instances
that's app engine CPU Google Cloud
datastore read operations back-end
instances that's also app engine CPU and
then bigquery flat rate annual we're a
big big for a user so we pay for flat
rate pricing great so now we've just
recreated what the billing report
already gives us so who cares what's the
point well the point is we can now
actually go into additional analysis and
one of the things that you might want to
do if you're a little bit crazy is
actually go reproduce your exact invoice
now this sounds a little silly and I
admit it is it doesn't serve a whole lot
of practical purpose but it is very
useful to be able to verify that
whatever conversions or analysis you're
doing is actually correct by matching
your Google Cloud bill if you want to do
this craziness Google provides you some
tools to make it actually easy first is
you provides this invoice month field
which gives you a year in month string
which is exactly which invoice that
particular record is going to end up on
from Google's bill so you can group by
that the second thing you're going to
want to do is you need to round your
cost and credits to two decimal places
at the line item or the SKU level so
this is this round to two decimal points
big query expression there
finally the export data will show tax as
one line item at the beginning of the
next month
whereas if you look at your PDF bill it
will actually show you your tax on
separate projects so if you're comparing
your PDF bill to your bigquery results
and really want it to add up you're
gonna have to do a little bit of math
and if you do this you actually get
exactly to your bill down to the exact
penny since December 2018 there's a
document in Google's billing
documentation which will show you some
exact query examples again is this
actually that useful it's useful for
debugging things but for the most part
if you don't do this you're going to get
within the nearest dollar anyway so you
don't necessarily have to do this
unless you're like me and are kind of
anal retentive and want to really make
sure that you got it right okay so now
what can we do with this we have our raw
billing data export into bigquery
we wouldn't want to actually go and look
at it and and be able to produce some
reports I suggest that you use data
studio again it's built into Google
cloud it's available for you for free
this is not a talk about data studio I'm
not gonna tell you how to use it or show
it to you there's lots of other talks
and resources about this again the
billing documentation itself provides
some examples but the point here is you
can now create custom dashboards from
this billing data the reason this is
useful is that there sometimes are
things in the the built-in Google
billing tool that you may want to come
back to multiple times like maybe you
want to look at here's the top cost for
our production project combined with
some cost for some of our top line items
in a separate chart you can create a
dashboard and data studio just by
pointing and clicking save that as a
link share it with others look at it
every single day so again this is this
is still the same data that's available
in that billing report thing but now you
can customize it to look at stuff that
is actually relevant to you and make
that easier I also just find data studio
to be a useful tool to know about if you
need to do some ad hoc visualization of
bigquery stuff or other data sources
anyway so let's useful to play with okay
so this is basically the built-in Google
Cloud billing tools so now let's talk
about what other data sources we might
want to use to get more detail on this
so as a reminder the point here is we
have these big line items that are left
so for example we in this big blue bar
what the heck is in this thing we'd like
to know more detail about where that's
coming
from so there are other data sources
about what you're using on Google cloud
that you can go and pull some of this
from has some examples on App Engine you
have request logs that tell you every
request that came into your application
for bigquery there are query logs that
tell you about every query that got
executed for pub/sub there are
stackdriver metrics that tell you about
the total bytes going into and out of
your topics for kubernetes storage and
compute there our usage exports that
will tell you various granularities of
usage data about those things and so we
can go and combine these these existing
usage data things with our bill to find
out what are in those big line items so
here's the plan we're going to get the
usage per day for one of these large
line items that we want to understand in
more detail we're then going to combine
that information with our official bill
to get like a usage metric per dollar
and then we're going to produce an
annotated bill that has that original
data from Google a lot but broken out
into these separate categories with this
additional annotation so the exact way
you do this is going to depend a little
bit on the resource that you want to
break down I'm going to talk through
what we did for app engine CPU just
because that is for Google this is the
largest line-item that are for us Siri
for blue core the largest line-item that
we have the largest line-item we have
currently is App Engine front-end
instances which is CPU time an app
engine we started five or six years ago
as an app engine application it's still
our biggest line-item today so how do we
do this App Engine has these request
logs and they look like this you do not
need to understand what is on this slide
but the point is there's a whole lot of
data in this existing request log and
when we were looking at this we noticed
hey there's this line item here that
says megacycles 29 what the heck is that
if you look at that fitness
documentation it says something like
this is a suggestion of how much CPU is
used by this request but it's actually
not very accurate you know user B won't
and be warned so we wanted to know okay
well this says it may or may not be
accurate what can we do with it so we
went to date a studio and produced a
visualization of our total app engine
cost at the top so this is the data from
the Google Cloud billing export per day
for this one line item and then we went
and summed
this megacycles value out of the opinion
request logs over that same time period
and so what do you see when you see
these two graphs to me that's pretty
damn close if you look at these two
blobs here you'll notice that they're
not actually completely identical
there's a little bit of difference
between these two things but that's
pretty close so fine maybe there's some
error here maybe we're off by 1% maybe
we're off by 5% I'm not sure but this
seems like this is probably a useful
data source for us and in some
experimentation that we've done by
fixing some things we've sort of
verified that it is it is close so now
what do we do well what we can do is sum
the megacycles per day out of this app
engine log to get a total and then we
can compute what the cost per mega cycle
per day was so you know 10,000 mega
cycles per dollar something like this
now we can actually compute the cost for
each request because each request has
this megacycles value on it and we can
aggregate these URL paths by team and by
customer to break down the annotation to
get that level of detail that we want
there's going to be some stuff left over
and in our case we just account this to
unknown because we're not going to get a
hundred percent of our coverage and
again that's okay that's one of the
points here is we don't need this to be
completely a hundred percent accurate we
just need it to be like 90 percent
accurate or 95 percent accurate so what
does this look like well we end up oh
sorry the next part I should point out
is this is actually a relative cost I
don't actually know what is how much
does a mega cycle cost you I don't know
Google doesn't tell us it doesn't really
make sense but as a relative usage a
fraction of our usage of app engine
resources it's a useful measure and
there's lots of other resources that
sort of look like this as well where you
can say well this is a percentage of our
cost for this day and you can break it
out that way so this what this looks
like is this proves to the table that
has say each day in this case this is
march 18th a URL path or our URL prefix
and then a cost that it cost us for that
particular URL prefix so when we've gone
and done this with Ferg blinkers bill
our app engine CPU annotation gets us
about 30% 38% of our bill we get that
sort of team customer breakdown for 38%
from that we've also had to go and do
this annotation for bigquery queries
like I said that was
number four line item so we do the sort
of same thing by looking at the bigquery
query log and we've also done this for
datastore storage by looking at this
data source storage export data or usage
data that we then export out of data
store we'll do it for these three line
items we now have 49 percent of our bill
that's left where we don't have this
team and customer level of detail so
this isn't quite good enough we got 51
percent but we still need to know what's
in some of this 49 percent before we
know that we have an accurate enough
estimate of our costs per team or per
customer so what can we do now we're
going to have to go instrument our code
to get more detail about what's in that
remaining bucket so here's our plan
we're going to go instrument our code
we're going to go and instrument our
application in some way we're going to
emit that data in our case we emit it in
logs which then end up in bigquery
through the stack driver logging export
and then we're gonna go aggregate this
usage data by day which will then look
like what we did before with Google's
own data sources we're going to get some
amount of usage for these additional
line items on a daily basis which we can
then combine with the bill so as an
example we did this for data store gets
inputs like I said we're an app engine
application this is another large line
item for us it was the original sort of
storage layer for App Engine and the way
you get charged for it is you get
charged for every get you do and every
put you do against this operation so we
want to count how many we have so we
have to go and wrap in our application
all the get and put calls to count how
many actually happened
we then log the counts at the end of
each web request so that we can find out
for that particular request how many do
we actually do and then we aggregate
these in bigquery using it's like JSON
extract function which lets you pull
fields out of JSON payloads so the log
that we emit looks something like this
where we have a counts section with the
various counts we care about in this
case this is data store gets and data
store puts and then we also attach this
namespace thing so this is from our
application we have a concept of a
namespace which basically maps to the
customer and so this is why we actually
do this on a per request basis is so
that we can get back down to that level
of granularity of a single customer and
then we can run bigquery queries across
our logs just basically sum these up and
aggregate those together
so what does this look like well now we
can get a table that looks something
like this where we produce for a single
day and a URL path or prefix how many
gets inputs we did these are absolute
costs google tells us how much these
actually cost so now these just
translate directly into dollars so this
is actually a little bit easier than the
case where you only have a relative cost
metric where you have sort of a fraction
of usage this one we can just basically
do the math and say great this URL
prefix cost this much because of our you
know the price from Google so here's an
example here's what our actual detailed
cost schema looks like this is the the
sort of final output of all of these
series of jobs that we've done this may
or may not be the ideal schema it's
worked for us hopefully you can use it
for some inspiration if you come up with
a better one please tell me I'd love to
know so what does this look like first
here the first most important field is
this usage day specific this matches
Google's billing days so this is this
mountain view standard time day of from
our bill the next fields we pull out are
the project service and SKU or line item
these are the dimensions from the
billing exports these are fields that we
group buy from Google's original billing
data we then pull out the cost usage
amount and credits these are the metrics
from Google's billing data so we sum
these out of Google's existing bill the
cost is the actual cost usage amount is
sum per service metric so for datastore
it'll be read operations for Google
Cloud storage it'll be gigabyte seconds
or something like this and then credits
are the credit value and the key part
that we done is we have two additional
custom dimensions that we've added so we
again have this namespace which for us
is effectively a customer and this cost
category which is basically a software
component which we can then map back to
a particular team and the point that we
try to the constraint that we try to
continue to make sure we meet here is
that if we sum this table on some of
these dimensions that it adds up back to
Google's bill so we're adding these
custom dimensions as additional detail
again on the bill so how do we actually
produce this so we get some original
billing data so as an example we have a
particular day March 18th a particular
it'll actually be a project
and ask you but for simplicity I'm just
showing the skew here datastore gets and
we have some sort of cost for this so it
cost us $2,000 on that day we then have
instrumented our application to produce
this usage data of showing for that day
some URL path did 2400 gets some URL
path did 29,000 gets and again we can
translate that back to cost so we can
combine these two things to produce this
annotated bill which now has three line
items so it has one data store gets four
say team a we have some mapping from
these URL paths back to these cost
composed categories or teams and how
much that actually cost we have data
store gets for team B and then again
there's going to be some left over we
don't annotate we don't instrument every
single application that we run we just
try to instrument the big users and so
there's some left over in this case say
363 dollars and again that's okay we
don't need to be perfect we just need to
get most of it in order to be able to
make the right optimization decisions so
now that we've done this we managed to
get of cover 51% of our bill just by
using Google's built-in other usage data
sources so we were able to get 51% of
our bill down to this team and customer
level without necessarily going
instrument your application and a blue
core we've then gone an instrumented a
couple of data sources so data store
reads and writes is one example there's
a couple of others that we've done as
well that gets us like another 24
percent of our total bill down to this
cost category and customer level there's
going to be some left over in our case
it's currently about 25% and in our case
this percentage continues to grow this
remaining bucket continues to grow over
time and our approach has been once it
gets too large we go and look at it and
figure out what do we have to instrument
next what usage data can we import next
and the point again here is you don't
have to be perfect about it we just need
to get it right enough and get enough of
the data correct and for us this is sort
of accurate enough great so now let's
talk a little bit about some of the
lessons that we've learned through going
and doing this the first one is you
really want a break cost down to teams
because that is what actually makes
metrics actionable is when you can get
the responsibility down to a small
enough pool of people
what is small enough it's kind of going
to depend on your organization but in
hula course case when it was 40
engineers and we said hey datastore
costs went up last week that was too
large everyone just sort of looked
around and been like it wasn't I don't
know it wasn't my problem you need to
get down to a small enough group of
people set when you can tell say that to
someone they're like oh actually we did
something last week maybe we should look
at this as an example here's a cost for
one line item over 24 days this starts
at zero it goes up to question mark
number and when I look at this I say
maybe something happened to there at the
end I don't know there's a lot of
variation so this is what our this is
what our bill looked like I can't member
I think this was in January here is that
same line item if we look at just the
responsibility for one team for one cost
category again this starts at 0 is the
same 24 days and you can now tell holy
crap this went up by a factor of two for
this particular team maybe we should
look and look at this sure enough we
like to look at it here's that same team
SKU over 46 days we went and fixed the
problem the cost went back down to
normal after this so this is just an
example of you need to get the metrics
to the level of granularity that worked
for your organization so that you can go
and look at something and say hey
there's definitely something wrong here
it's definitely in this in this
particular part of our product or our
software
let's go and fix the problem this
actually leads to another interesting
part is in the cloud when you are using
a lot of these automatic scaling
features performance bugs actually
become cost bugs and I think this is
actually great this is actually an
improvement in the old world when you
had a performance problem where your
load went up there was some sort of
error retrying or customer load when
that happen your service just went down
so you knew about the problem right away
but it also meant that your your
application was broken and your service
was broken if you're using a lot of
these auto scaling things your service
is just going to continue to work it
just might cost you a heck of a lot so
you do need to keep an eye on these
sorts of things to be able to find these
problems before they cost you a lot of
money there are built in Google features
for this by the way there are billing
alerts that you can set on various
levels of granularity there are all
sorts of other things you can do
finally my big point is again mate
metrics that matter for your team what
was worked for blue core may or may not
work for you and your team but the data
is there and you can go and do it you
can break it down to the level of
granularity you want it is possible to
go and annotate this stuff to figure out
where you're used to just going you just
have to go do a little bit of work and
it's not actually that hard to learn
more today there's a couple of other
sessions still left 10 20 there's
automated cost optimizations on GCP 115
there's a lining cloud costs with
service delivery you can go to the cost
management showcase and talk to some of
the Google PM's who are working on these
sorts of things and if you have
questions about it there's the ask the
expert booth and definitely go and look
at the cost management documentation on
Google cloud on cloud.google.com it has
details about all this stuff that I
talked about today like how to set up
and use the billing export what does
this scheme actually mean
[Music]